- [Voiceover] This
animation is brought to you
by the SMART Imagebase,
a subscription website where
you can download thousands
of medical images and
videos to use in lectures,
courses, presentations,
professional training, and more.
For more information, click on
the link in the description.
- [Instructor] A series of events called
the menstrual cycle happens
about once every month
to prepare a woman's body for pregnancy.
Changing levels of natural chemicals
in the bloodstream called
hormones control these events.
The reproductive organs
affected by these hormones
include the vagina,
cervix,
uterus,
fallopian tubes,
and ovaries.
The ovaries produce two main hormones
called estrogen and progesterone.
As the level of estrogen begins to rise,
It causes the normally thick mucus
inside the cervix to thin out.
Estrogen also triggers other hormones
to cause one of the
ovaries to release an egg.
This process is called ovulation.
If a woman has sex during this time,
a man's reproductive cells called sperm
can pass through the thinner
mucus to fertilize an egg.
In the uterus, estrogen
causes the lining to thicken
which prepares it to
receive a fertilized egg.
Rising progesterone levels
cause glands in the
lining to release fluid
that feeds the fertilized egg.
Progesterone also causes
the thinned out mucus in the cervix
to become thick again,
which prevents sperm from passing through.
If an egg hasn't been fertilized
the levels of both estrogen
progesterone begin to fall.
This drop in hormone
levels causes menstruation,
a process where the uterus
sheds its inner tissue lining
and blood through the vagina.
A progestin implant is a form
of birth control or a contraception.
It prevents pregnancy
for up to three years.
The device is implanted
under the skin in a woman's upper arm.
A progestin implant is
a matchstick size flexible plastic rod
containing a progesterone-like
hormone called progestin.
It's designed to be able
to show up on x-rays.
The implant continually
releases progestin in the body.
High progestin levels
help prevent the body
from releasing other hormones
that cause ovulation.
Without ovulation,
there is no egg available
for fertilization,
so a woman can't get pregnant.
A second way progestin prevents pregnancy
involves its effect on
the mucus in the cervix.
High progestin levels keep
the mucus in the cervix thick enough
so sperm can't get through it.
A third way progestin prevents pregnancy
involve its influence on
the lining of the uterus.
In contrast to natural progesterone,
progestin is slightly
different chemically.
Over time,
it makes the uterine lining
thinner instead of thicker.
As a result, if fertilization
of an egg does take place
the lining may be too thin
for it to stay in the uterus,
so it passes out of the body
with the next menstrual period.
A doctor can insert a progestin implant
during an office visit.
To do this,
the doctor will make two
marks with a sterile marker.
One for the insertion site,
and a second mark used
as a direction guide during insertion.
Then the insertion area will
be cleaned with an antiseptic
and numbed with a local anesthetic.
Next, the doctor will
use a special applicator
to puncture the skin with a hollow needle
containing the implant and
slide it beneath the skin.
Finally, the needle will be removed
leaving implant behind.
After the implant is placed
the doctor will ensure proper placement
by feeling for both ends of
the implant under the skin.
A bandage will be placed
over the insertion site.
Menstrual bleeding with
a progestin implant
may include changes in bleeding frequency,
bleeding intensity, and duration
of each bleeding period.
Although the implant can be removed sooner
it must be removed after three years.
A doctor can replace it with
a new implant at that time.
If pregnancy is suspected, it's important
for a woman to see her
healthcare provider.
The implant may need to be moved.
A progestin implant is
over 99% effective at
preventing pregnancy.
This means less than 1 out of 100 women
will become pregnant each year
using this form of birth control.
For more information on
any type of birth control
talk to your healthcare provider.